are you gonna be there tonight i'm not  sure  am i gonna text you i don't think so  am i gonna park straight no  am i gonna leave a mess yes  am i gonna do laundry no am i gonna put  away my laundry not that either mom i'm  feeling some pent up frustration oh no  none  none oh wait let me go let's go look out  here  hannah's shoes where did she leave them  there  do i have to put them wow mom are you  neatly organized shoe show are you  frustrated by something right here  interesting hannah should i get a dog in  college no you're not responsible enough  to get a dog in college but let's bring  home this beautiful little girl  whose dog is it now mine